much good afternoon everyone
we have gathered at a very extraordinary
situation and i'm happy that
many
supporting
friends
come to show support to our currently
and who also ensure the security of the
region together we had an exchange of
opinions
we
expressed our views to the situation in
ukraine we also coordinated our actions
uh on the future ministerials
of nato ministers
and the eu
ministers foreign ministers meeting
the main
things that we have discussed are
further
support and assistance to ukraine we
have agreed that we can no longer
make a half step only we have to do
everything that is possible
to support ukraine in in military in
financial and economic means
and the same applies to sanctions
we can not
say a without saying be
we have to
try to ensure that all banks
in russia
are cut off from swift we have to start
speaking about
the imports of energy resources from
russia
we also should not forget that belarus
is a counterpart
of this aggression against ukraine
um
and the third element that we have
discussed in our meeting today is uh
military support to ukraine to the
baltic states i'm sorry
we have
to move on from deterrence to defense
and this is why we need a change of
political approach we also need
practical means for that and they are
needed for all three baltic states
so that
if putin decides to test nato uh
resistance in this region would be
responded right way would get a response
a political response and also a clear
defensive response if that would be
needed thank you
and now
secretary of state of the uk
thank you minister langberges for
bringing us here together in vilnius
the united kingdom
stands with our allies in doing all we
can to support ukraine against president
putin's war of choice
we must ensure putin fails in this
horrific enterprise and his ambitions go
no further
we were pleased to support lithuania's
leadership referring war crimes to the
icc
i'm here today in vilnius with our
baltic friends
because i want to say that the uk's
commitment to the baltics and to article
5 are unyielding
our baltic friends know what's at stake
having long lived in the shadow of
russian aggression and i admire your
courage
we're working together to deliver two
clear objectives
first putin must lose in ukraine
we're helping ukraine defend itself
our defensive weapons from the united
kingdom are now being used to stop
russian tracks but we need to do more
secondly we must contain this aggression
we are reinforcing nato's eastern flank
and supporting european security through
the uk-led joint expeditionary force
we are here in the baltic region
we lead and have doubled our enhanced
forward presence in estonia
our allies are leading
troops across the baltics
british military intelligence are
working with lithuania's military to
enhance border defensive
including
in the sulvaki gap
200 troops are doing joint military
exercises right now and we're working
together on maritime security
at the nato foreign ministers meeting
tomorrow
we will be working together to
strengthen our collective defense
in the light of the change security
situation across europe
in terms of supporting ukraine with
defensive weaponry
the united kingdom was the first
european country to give defensive
military support to ukraine
and we are now also supporting with the
humanitarian aid
we've pledged 220 million in aid support
to ukraine and we're the top european
donor and we will do more
we've also been at the forefront in
tightening the vice on the kremlin
through sanctions and it's vital at this
juncture that we keep our foot on the
gas
we've worked with the us the eu and g7
to cuff off funding for putin's war
machine
kicking russian banks out of the
financial system
we've also shut our air space to russian
planes and we're fast forwarding
sanctions against russian oligarchs
but we need to go further
we need to make sure no russian bank
has access to swift
and we need to go further on reducing
dependency on hydrocarbons from russia
including oil gas and coal
we've also launched sanctions against
belarus
for aiding and abetting aggression
i will be raising these issues
at the g7 tomorrow and also at the
european union foreign affairs council
alongside the united states canada and
ukraine who have also been invited in
these extraordinary circumstances
this is a struggle not just for
ukraine's freedom and self-determination
but for all of our freedom and
security by continuing to respond with
strengths we will together ensure
that putin loses
and we stand
with our brave allies here in the
baltics to do just that
thank you
yes
foreign minister
well i would like to thank cabrillos for
bringing us together for this
very much needed discussion and
coordination among our baltic friends
and together with our very close ally
united kingdom
we focus mainly on discussing
war started by russia in europe and how
we could support
ukraine more than we have done so far i
think we have done a lot but i agree
that we have to do more we have to
continue to support ukraine politically
financially and also to help with them
to defend their country their
sovereignty and territorial integrity
but most importantly today
also the lives of the people of
ukraine ukraine is european country and
what we see at the moment ukraine is a
country who is protecting european
values in front line of europe
from estonia side we continue to support
ukrainians transatlantic aspirations and
also support ukrainian candidacy to the
eu
we have to continue to send supportive
messages to ukraine to support a people
in this very difficult circumstances
at the same time of course we must do of
atmos to stop the war and to stop the
war we of course need to
raise the cost of war and
here we have
made good decisions but we need to do
more so that the cost of war for russia
would be expensive and this war stops
i think that also it's very important to
use all political means to take
aggression
account because
these war crimes that we see taking
place while we are speaking here these
people who are behind this they must be
taken accountable for their actions
finally i also would like to explain
express estonia's
appreciation towards the united kingdom
who is leading country of efp mission in
estonia we really are thankful for
quick the seasons
that we have seen over the last few
weeks
by doubling uk troops in estonia and we
very much look forward to to orders the
seasons at the nato level how we could
have
permanent
decisions for our region
how we permanently strengthen the
eastern flank of
europe
of europe because of nato because the
security situation in europe has changed
and the power of balance has changed so
we have to make adjustments um within
nato
so i look forward to our tomorrow's
meeting at the eu and
nato and of course
hope that this war that has started by
russia will end soon thank you
latviews
latvian foreign minister edwell in
cabbage gabrieles for being excellent
host and thank you very much elise for
coming and also
having great discussion with us and also
showing the full solidarity and support
to the baltic states
it's uh actually very difficult to speak
as the last speaker because everything
has been said by
previous colleagues speaking and i think
that i can agree with everything
however let me stress three points
number one
and that's about our strategy i think
how to deal with this very difficult
situation number one
we must continue supporting ukraine in
any way we can i think that we are in
agreement here ukraine needs diplomatic
support ukraine needs political support
ukraine needs economic support and
ukraine needs support
through military means i think that this
is where we are absolutely clear and we
have had very good exchange
among ourselves about the ways how we
can further
have this assistance second we must stop
russia
from further aggression
and that's where
sanctions diplomatic pressure come in
place
well i'm very satisfied with the way how
european union
g7 nato has been acting in the past
seven days i think that i can only agree
with my colleagues that we still have
plenty of work to do
we still haven't closed some locals we
still need to
ensure that there are further economic
sanctions against russia but also the
same set of sanctions must be applied
against belarus because belarus is
complicit of the aggression that russian
federation is committing
and also belarus could be used by
russia
to actually avoid some of the harshest
effects of sanctions so from that point
of view we must have sanctions that
target both
aggressors russia and belarus
and the third is the
uh regional security
i do believe that nato has been very
successful establishing deterrence
mission in this region
after events of 2014 after occupation of
crimea but i think that we are in the
next phase where we must exercise
deterrence on defense
we are very grateful to those allies who
have already sent more troops to the
region but we also know that we need to
respond to the very quickly changing
situation i know that many people
are asking how safe are the baltic
states
or poland or any of eastern flank
nations i think that the presence of the
foreign secretary here
the discussions that we are having at
nato and we are going to have tomorrow
since a very clear
signal that
there is ironclad commitment by nato to
do its work
uh there is concrete discussion and
plans and also actions already taken and
i think that we all understand that
we will see this kind of
challenging situation as long as
there is the current leadership in
russia and even beyond so we must be
prepared for a very long-term engagement
addressing all those three elements i
was just talking so
thank you very much one more time
thank you very much also to colleagues
for a very efficient and very fruitful
discussion we had this morning
now members of the media it's your time
to ask you make ask in english or in
lithuanian please come to the microphone
introduce yourself and uh and tell whom
the question is intended too
from baltic news service my question is
for all the ministers in recent days
perception of russia and its threat
shifted dramatically in the western
world uh however some experts claim that
it's not enough and the only way to stop
putin is
for nato to interfere otherwise russia
will go further causing more harm and
what's your take uh on that and can
sanctions alone
make russia stop war and withdraw its
troops thank you very much
i will respond in lithuanian
i think that my colleagues
everyone here have
drawn a clear guidelines
for
our future results
and the directions where we need to work
most to focus most now
so the further strengthening of the
eastern flank of nato by uh
focusing on the baltic states
continuing to support ukraine
and providing assistance to ukraine and
unbearable sanctions
against russia these are
our
major tasks for the coming days i would
say even
there are three
there are three clear elements of our
strategy
first of all is supporting
ukraine in their self-defense
both economically
and with defensive weaponry and we have
seen a huge step up
in terms of the number of nations
committing to that
we've recently seen germany shift our
poli their policy which is extremely
welcome
and that support is being felt and
what we are seeing is russia being
surprised by the level and strength of
resistance in ukraine and very very
brave actions
by the ukrainian president
and the ukrainian people the second
thing we need to do is degrade the
russian economy
to stop the ability to fund putin's war
machine
and of course the banking measures are
key to that the measures of swift the
measures we took against the central
bank but it's also important that we
need to reduce dependence on
hydrocarbons which ultimately
have given putin the ability to fund
this terrible destruction
and the final point is strengthening
nato's eastern flank in response to what
is a new
uh security situation in europe and that
is why i'm here today
in vilnius to show the united kingdom's
commitment uh to strengthen the flank we
will have further discussions tomorrow
at the nato foreign ministers but we are
absolutely determined to ensure the
peace and security of all of those
countries right across nato
minister limits please
thank you from estonia side we have the
same view that we must continue to
support ukraine politically but also
with defense means and also
make it clear for russia that this
unjustified war must end
and the cost for this more for this war
for russia is a big one
with regard to
defense support for ukraine then over
this last few days we have seen that
more than 20 countries have already
agreed to support
uh ukraine so really ukraine gets strong
support to defend their country and
territorial integrity of their country
so we definitely continue to support
these directions and invite also other
like-minded countries to do the same
and with regard to nato's it's um of
course uh we must really take into
account this current security concerns
and developments and and continue to
strengthen defense and deterrence
posture of nato thank you
ministering
well
thank you very much i think that again
my colleagues already outlined basically
all those points that i wanted to stress
and
i could agree with them but let me just
say one thing
i do believe that
such
decisions as nato involvement
are the last resort decisions and they
are being taken by all 30 member states
so
that's number one number two
i do believe and i think that we should
be prepared
uh to work on uh even harsher sanctions
not excluding the possibility of
sanctioning also oil and gas sector that
is
as you may imagine very important to
russia and here i very much agree with
secretary trust
when uh julius were alluding that the
main
target currently is to make sure that
russian economy and financial system is
not able to fund russian war machine if
we get this right
then we can avoid
uh any other scenarios and i think that
we still have avenues to to explore and
to work together thank you
between lithuanian national broadcaster
a question for madame truss
russia for many years expressed an
aggressive point of view of history
they've tried to rewrite it and we see
right now that many russian people do
not believe that the war is happening
do you believe that the sanctions could
spark resistance inside the russia and
lead to changes thank
you well the
your question is absolutely correct
about the clearly expressed ambitions of
president putin
but i don't believe he speaks on behalf
of russian people and what we have seen
over the last week is some very brave
people
in russia
protesting standing up against the
regime and we need to make sure we get
the information to them
about what is actually happening it's
much harder to control information
in the world of social media
and
we need to make sure as i've said that
the russian economy
is crippled so it is unable to continue
to fund putin and the war machine and i
suspect uh that the russian people will
draw their own conclusions from that
i believe we have a question from
zaitong you very much uh kai schtadman
from germany deutsche said i have a
question for mr lansberges which goes a
little bit beyond europe
given your problems
with china and taiwan last year
could you first maybe make a short
comment on china's role in this crisis
now and secondly
especially in germany we've seen a lot
of soul searching and regret about our
recent naivete
towards russia and the authoritarian
nature of its regime
would you think that
there are lessons from this also towards
our relationship with china in the
future thank you
i think that
all of us are going through a soul
search
seeing what's happening in in ukraine
and what
russian military machine is able and
capable of doing
with uh direct orders coming from
kremlin from putin
um
probably this is one of the
few capitals
in the world
where
a year ago 10 years ago
you could have asked
how do we see the situation
and many people would have predicted
what is happening now
it doesn't give a different moral
obligation now currently but you would
have a lot of people who are
very clear sighted
or what could come next
so probably answering also your first
question is um
it's not that big of a surprise
that
a stand
for taiwan happened here as well
it was born out of the same roots
of
defending the principles
that bore our independence
and that help defend
the freedom that we so much cherish
television news a question for both
lithuanian and latvian ministers because
you mentioned this as you said that
we've been working on deterrence and now
we have to go to defense can you please
explain what that would mean practically
thank you
well i think that it's
first of all it's an important political
shift in the decision-making process
when we were talking and we still are
talking about deterrence
uh
russian troops
were
hundreds of kilometers away from nato
borders
they were securely stationed in their
bases
spending their summers winters
in a somewhat
controllable environment
now they are very close
to
nato borders
engaged in the military action
unprovoked military action against an
independent sovereign country ukraine
so it merits an answer
from a defensive alliance
that this this alliance it's not only
about sending a political message
deterring message
but it's a about a very specific
instruments that would be used
for defense
and i won't go into specific tactical
details it's best if they are mentioned
by
people from another ministry
from minister of
but
i think
all areas
for defending our region should be
looked at
it means air defense
ground defense maritime defense they
think they all need a very sharp and
specific look
okay just very quickly to add
to what gabriella said
i think that
so far deterrence really worked well but
now we must
revisit
based on the experience that we see in
ukraine and i think that there is plenty
of things to learn from ukrainians and
from what is happening to ukraine and
immediately to adapt in the nato defense
doctrine but
air defense capabilities need to be
strengthened maritime defense
capabilities must be strengthened more
boots on the ground must be put in
command control elements must be
strengthened and one thing that i want
to stress which is equally important
it's not like military defense but also
cyber defense must be revisited and
cyber defense
operations must be
also put on an equal footing when we
speak about defending any of nato
countries or nato territory in the 21st
century and of course my most favorite
subject is of also
fighting back uh this information i
think that what we are seeing right now
using information lying to the people
both in russia but also to the broader
public trying also to put some kind of
uneasiness
in nato countries
so that we have many questions
threatening nuclear weapons
those things also need to be addressed
in a collective way by our stratcoms
and
we are actually
facing unprecedented
uh let's say multi-disciplinary
situation
so from that point of view that is
something that i would
describe as
also initial thinking on what we should
do and what we are going to discuss not
only at nato foreign ministers level
also at experts level at defence
ministers level
and will be working
we have time for two last questions
colleague from the netherlands please
yes hello good afternoon mark deutscher
from nrc the netherlands for mr
lamberges
also about regional security and also
about the shift that's being announced
from deterrence to defence
what exactly
does it mean in in the practical way but
um
what is do you have a concrete wish list
for nato for for the meeting tomorrow
things have set in motion already but
what's what's the primary thing that has
to be none done next
and my second question is about the
specific situation of lithuania belarus
is nearby but also kaliningrad do you
have a good
view of what the military
situation is in kaliningrad
um
i think that we've covered
parts of your first question uh by by
answering uh last question
we do have a specific
wish list but it has to come from
first of all from the political decision
secondly from the planning that is done
by
by nato uh
planning
centers
uh let's call it that and um
and taking into account
a specific situation where
uh baltic saints find them their subs in
and there are some differences
within the countries and you mentioned
one specific
element that is unique for for lithuania
is that we have a border
with russia but to the west
we also do have a border with with
belarus to uh to these but it's a
more common practice
so looking into these
elements
we think that as a very specific
strategy has to be applied to
the region but also to lithuania due to
uh uniqueness of geography
if i were to mention specifics
but again it's just taking one element
out of the whole strategic approach i
would say that it's uh air defense
this is probably a um
a
number one
from our wish list
um i would like to add that at the
moment in nature we're also preparing a
new strategic concept and from our
perspective of course all these
assessment
of the
new security situation in europe must be
take taken into account for long term
and we must reflect all these
uh security problems that we have at the
moment in europe in strategic concept
and also provide permanent means and
solutions from nato
long term
bloomberg um a question to madame truss
um
thousands of people in ukraine are
fleeing to to the border and they need a
safe passage also medical supplies um
need to reach the most vulnerable
what can be done to achieve a
humanitarian corridor and
how could this be achieved thank you
well you you're absolutely right about
the dire situation and the united
kingdom has sent teams
to the border
to assist particularly in poland but
also in
other countries facing those issues
i was in geneva yesterday sorry the day
before yesterday meeting the un
and others to talk about making sure a
humanitarian corridor is established for
the safe passage of aid and humanitarian
support
of course we must continue to work
towards this school also at the united
nations level because for the
humanitarian corridors we need
agreement from uh
also from russia from ukraine for
all the fighting sites
and of course it's extremely difficult
as russia is the member of the united
nations security council
but definitely we must continue to have
this political pressure at the u.n level
and yesterday is the season by
united nations member states to clearly
show that russia is aggressor was a good
sign that the international community
understands where the problem is but we
need to continue to work at the un level
so that
there is another resolution to help to
establish this humanitarian
corridor in ukraine for these people
there
would you like to ask something
the press conference is over thank you
for your attention